[Musique]
en afghanistan les talibans se sont
emparés de trois nouvelles capitales de
province aujourd'hui dans le nord du
pays il contrôle désormais neuf des 34
capitale provinciale des membres des
forces de sécurité ont dû se rendre le
président asseraf gagny s'est rendu dans
le nord-est pour tenter de coordonner la
riposte malgré cette avancée des
insurgés joe biden dit ne pas regretter
le départ des troupes américaines
en france nouvelles mesures du
gouvernement pour faire face à la crise
sanitaire confinement strict en
guadeloupe fin de la gratuité des tests
ou encore une campagne de rappel pour
une troisième doses pour les personnes
les plus fragiles la crise sanitaire des
pas derrière nous et durera encore a
avertit emmanuel macron
[Musique]
il y un an jour pour jour la russie
annonce l enregistrement de soutenir et
le tout premier vaccin au monde contre
le colis de 19 avec une efficacité
il est convoité dans les pays de
l'hémisphère sud mais l' agence
européenne des médicaments ne sont
presque pas pour autant de l'homologuer
on le verra
[Musique]
et
bonsoir à tous il est 20h bienvenue si
vous nous rejoignez sur rt france et on
démarre en afghanistan où les talibans
se sont emparés de trois nouvelles
capitales de province aujourd'hui dans
le nord du pays et des membres des
forces de sécurité ont dû se rendre le
président a sera organisée rendus sur
place pour tenter de coordonner la
riposte
neuf des 34 capitale provinciale de
l'afghanistan a désormais aux mains des
insurgés
sept sont situés dans le nord du pays
une région qui leur avait pourtant
toujours résisté malgré l'avancée des
insurgés joe biden confirme que les
soldats américains auront bien
quittaient l'afghanistan fin août à des
combats qui poussent des dizaines de
milliers de civils à fuir leur foyer
françois xavier lambert
dans ce parc de kaboul des centaines de
réfugiés attendent d'être ravitaillés en
eau et nourriture
voici l'une des conséquences de la vaste
offensive lancée en mai dernier par les
talibans alors que les insurgés gagnent
chaque jour un peu plus de terrain face
aux forces gouvernementales
des milliers de civils fuient les
combats depuis le début de l'année près
de trois cent soixante mille afghans ont
été déplacées selon l'organisation
internationale pour les migrations
je suis arrivé hier soir à cause des
affrontements je viens de char dara dans
la région de koundouz
nous n'avons rien à manger et rien pour
nous couvrir nous avons donné de
l'argent à un chauffeur qui nous a
conduits jusqu'ici nous vivons des
épreuves il n'y a rien à manger et aucun
abri
les talibans contrôlent désormais neuf
des 34 capitale provinciale et tentent
de s'emparer de la grande ville du nord
afghan mazar i sharif ils ont jusqu'à
présent été repoussée mais maintiennent
la pression sur des troupes afghanes qui
semble démuni sans le soutien aérien
américain les troupes américaines sont
censées avoir quitté l'afghanistan le 31
août prochain malgré la menace d'une
prise de pouvoir total des talibans joe
biden a de nouveau assuré ne pas
regretter sa décision
[Musique]
je pense qu'ils commencent à réaliser
qu'ils doivent s'unir politiquement plus
haut niveau et nous allons continuer à
tenir notre engagement mais je ne
regrette pas ma décision
face à la déroute de leurs armes et les
autorités afghanes assurent vouloir
encore négocier avec les talibans elle
met aussi en garde sur la présence de
nombreux combattants d'al qaïda aux
côtés des insurgés
[Musique]
notre priorité absolue reste la paix et
le dialogue en vue d'un règlement
négocié à venir mais nous avons aussi un
autre travail à faire pour défendre
notre pays et notre peuple contre cette
violence accrue des talibans et d'autres
groupes terroristes
il y à al qaïda et d'autres terroristes
étrangers qui combattent aux côtés des
talibans contre le peuple afghan et le
gouvernement
dans l'espoir d'éviter l'instauration
d'un nouveau pouvoir taliban à kaboul
les échanges diplomatiques s'accélère
des représentants chinois occidentaux
pakistanais ou encore des nations unies
ont entamé une série de réunions à doha
ils vont tenter de relancer un processus
de paix qui n'a jamais vraiment démarré
entre le pouvoir afghan et des insurgés
qui privilégie l'option de la force et
face au combat à l'allemagne les
pays-bas annoncent la suspension des
expulsions de migrants afghans vers leur
pays d'origine une volte face pour ces
deux pays la semaine dernière avec les
belges les danois les grecs et les
autrichiens il avait demandé à la
commission européenne de maintenir la
possibilité d'expulser des migrants
afghans malgré un appel de kaboul à
interrompre ces expulsions aient
décision justifiée aujourd'hui par
l'évolution de la situation sécuritaire
la situation en afghanistan est
susceptible de changer et les événements
pour la période à venir sont si un
certain que j'ai décidé d'introduire un
moratoire sur les décisions d'expulsions
et les départs le moratoire sur les
décisions et les départs s'applique pour
une durée de six mois et s'applique aux
ressortissants étrangers de nationalité
afghane et pour continuer de décrypter
la situation en afghanistan on va
retrouver notre correspondant à
washington thomas bonnin
bonsoir thomas alors face à la percée
des talibans en afghanistan le
gouvernement américain ne semble pas
remettre en question finalement le
départ des troupes du pays comment
réagissent les autorités américaines à
la situation sur place
et bien en fait on a deux versions il ya
d'abord évidemment la version officielle
mais il ya aussi cette version qu'on a
notamment pu lire dans les colonnes du
washington post qui cite des sources
anonymes et on sent poindre une forme
d'inquiétude parmi ces sources proches
du dossier des personnes qui travaillent
vraisemblablement au sein de
l'administration de la maison blanche
ces personnes ces sources elle estime
par exemple que kaboul pourraient tomber
aux mains des talibans bien plus vite
que ce qui était initialement prévu par
les services de renseignement américains
on parle d'un mois voire 90 jours avant
que la capitale afghane ne soit donc
occupées par les forces armées des
talibans alors évidemment il ya
maintenant cette question qui a été
posée d'ailleurs au président américain
joe biden est ce qu'il regrette sa
décision de retirer les troupes
américaines d'afghanistan écoutez sa
réponse
non écoutés nous avons dépensé plus de
mille milliards de dollars sur 20 ans
nous avons formé et équipé plus de
300000 forces afghanes avec du matériel
moderne et les dirigeants afghans
doivent s'unir
nous avons perdu des milliers des
milliers de personnels américains des
milles deux morts et deux blessés ils
doivent se battre pour eux mêmes se
battre pour leur nation
les états unis insisterons pour que nous
continuons à tenir les engagements que
nous avons pris en fournissant un
soutien aérien rapproché en veillant à
ce que les forces aériennes fonctionne
et soit opérationnel en
réapprovisionnant leurs forces en
nourriture et en équipements et en
payant tout leur salaire mais il faut
qu'ils aient envie de se battre ils sont
plus nombreux que les talibans et je
reçois des briefings quotidiens
je pense qu'il ya encore une possibilité
ils ont un nouveau secrétaire à la
défense important notre équivalent du
secrétaire à la défense en afghanistan
ismaïl khan qui est un combattant
sérieux je pense qu'ils commencent à
réaliser qu'ils doivent s'unir
politiquement au sommet mais nous allons
continuer à tenir notre engagement mais
je ne regrette pas ma décision
vous l'avez entendu aucun regret de la
part du président américain joe biden
est en réalité pour le gouvernement des
états unis ce n'est pas inéluctable que
les talibans prennent possession d'une
majorité du territoire en afghanistan il
ya par exemple l'aide price le
porte-parole de la diplomatie américaine
qui a lui aussi rappelé que les forces
armées afghanes étaient plus nombreuses
que les talibans et qu'elle était
entraînée et soutenu logistiquement par
les forces armées américaines mais la
réalité du terrain elle vient elle est
un peu différente parce qu on comprend
aussi que les talibans prennent
possession dans un certain nombre
d'armes que possèdent les forces
gouvernementales et on voit aussi des
témoignages affluent et de soldats de
l'armée afghane qui quittent leurs
fonctions par peur justement est bien de
ses offensives des talibans dans le pays
la crainte en réalité c'est un scénario
qui pourrait être un scénario similaire
à celui de l'irak en 2011 rappelez-vous
à l'époque les forces armées américaines
s'étaient retirés du pays mais avait dû
se redéployer quelques années plus tard
parce que il y avait l'émergence de
l'état islamique dans le pays alors
évidemment cette situation n'est pas
encore sait pas encore ce qui se passe
en afghanistan on en est mais s'il ya
une situation de chaos avec des
conséquences qui pourraient finalement
être assez similaire à celle qu'on a
connue en irak c'est par exemple ce
qu'affirme une chercheuse afghane qui
est cité cette fois dans les colonnes du
new york times elle explique que les
états unis n'ont pas permis
l'établissement d'une stabilité
politique en afghanistan et que
finalement les autorités afghanes sont
encore très dépendante des états unis et
que le départ plutôt soudain des forces
armées affaiblit considérablement
justement le poids de ces autorités
afghanes en tout cas donc pas de retour
en arrière pour le moment de la part de
joe biden on verra si la stratégie est
adapté au cours des prochaines semaines
vous l'avez entendu il suit un briefing
quotidien sur la situation en
afghanistan il pourrait peut-être y
avoir des ajustements sur l'appui
logistique notamment l'appui aérien
fourni par les états unis mais il faut
bien comprendre que ce retrait des
troupes américaines d'afghanistan
eh bien il est validé largement par
l'opinion ici aux etats unis merci
beaucoup thomas pour toutes ces
précisions thomas bonnin en direct de
washington
en france une nouvelle série de mesures
prises par le gouvernement français pour
endiguer la propagation du co lead des
mesures locales et nationales comme un
confinement strict en guadeloupe le pass
sanitaire obligatoire dans certains
centres commerciaux ou encore une
campagne de rappel pour une troisième
dose à compter de la mi-septembre pour
les personnes vulnérables des annonces
faites par le porte parole du
gouvernement gabriela talent à l'issue
d'un conseil des ministres
extraordinaire
il a aussi déclaré que les tests sans
prescriptions seront payants dès la
mi-octobre écoutez
nous avons décidé ce matin d'acter la
fin de la gratuité des tests hors
prescription médicale devrait entrer en
vigueur à la mi octobre c'est conforme à
l'annonce qu'avait faite le président de
la république dans son allocution du 12
juillet c'est aussi conforme pas aux
choix que font un certain nombre de nos
voisins européens en ce moment je veux
rappeler sur ce point que les tests ne
protège pas les tests à répétition
n'empêche pas d'aller à l'hôpital et de
contaminer fortement d'ici mihocko
mi-octobre chacun aura eu le temps de
s'organiser et de prendre ses
responsabilités
et en tout cas la pandémie a eu bien des
effets sur l'économie française si les
pme ont été touchés par la crise ont dû
mettre la clé sous la porte ce n'est pas
le cas de toutes les entreprises
certaines ont brillé voire dépassé leurs
objectifs pendant cette période les
entreprises du cac 40 ont réalisé 60
milliards d'euros de profits au premier
semestre 2010 21 soit 41 % de plus qu'au
premier semestre 2010 9 et les fortunes
des patrons du cac 40 elles ont explosé
cette année les détails avec mon âme ou
dès lors et qu'elle allège que de
rebondissements de changement dans nos
quotidiens dans notre travail aussi
certains secteurs ont souffert plus que
d'autres depuis le début de cette crise
sanitaire et économique notamment lé pme
car vous allez le voir les entreprises
du cac 40 ont allégrement profité de
cette crise en quelques mots les riches
sont devenus encore plus riches alors
attention accrochez vous bien car ce
sont des chiffres qui donnent le tournis
alors que le monde d'avant s'écrouler
devant nos yeux que les suppressions
d'emplois s'enchaîner le patrimoine
cumulé des 500 plus grandes fortunes de
france a augmenté de 30% en un an selon
le classement de challenge le montant de
la fortune des 500 plus riche du pays
est désormais à deux mille milliards
d'euros qu'on comptait 95 milliardaire
français en 2020 en 2021 la famille
s'agrandit ils sont dorénavant 109 en
2021 pour la cinquième année consécutive
bernard arnault patron de lvmh est en
tête du classement des plus riches
première capitalisation boursière
d'europe avec une fortune estimée à plus
de 157 milliards il est en progression à
57% par rapport à jouer en 2020 arrivent
ensuite la famille hermès avec
81,5 milliards d'euros puis la famille
bettencourt avec
71,4 milliards d'euros des fortunes
poussé par la très forte reprise du
marché du luxe fin 2020 et le rebond des
marchés financiers
mais alors ces chiffres vertigineux sont
ils une bonne chose pour l'économie
française pas vraiment selon
l'organisation attac france les grands
gagnants vont être les actionnaires au
détriment de l'investissement
et de l'emploi on s'attend à des
versements particulièrement important de
dividende cette année quant à
l'enrichissement français il est en
grande partie lié aux mesures fiscales
appliquées ou même supprimer en france
avec par exemple la transformation de
l'impôt de solidarité sur la fortune en
impôts sur la fortune immobilière
peu après son arrivée au pouvoir
emmanuel macron a grandement alléger la
fiscalité des très riches cette symbiose
avec les patrons du cac 40 va encore
plus loin le gouvernement a débloqué des
aides publiques massives pour soutenir
le secteur privé pendant la pandémie et
les grandes entreprises du cac 40 en ont
largement bénéficié en connaissance de
cause de l'état et ses aides publiques
sont estimées à 150 5 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires en 2020 c'est colossal
et c'est un record en europe des
dizaines de milliards d'euros ont été
versées sans condition sociale fiscale
écologique alors que toutes les
entreprises n'étaient pas forcément dans
le besoin grâce à plusieurs mesures
prévues garantie chômage partiel ou
encore reports de charges beaucoup de
grands groupes comme safran
arcelormittal airbus ou encore renault
ont annoncé une réduction drastique de
leur effectif tout en continuant à
verser des dividendes
l'état est parfaitement au courant de la
bonne forme de ces entreprises puisque
cela se fait avec sa bénédiction les
sociétés dont il est actionnaire orange
et angie par exemple figurent parmi les
distributeurs de dividendes les plus
généreux atos bouygues ou encore vinci
qui ont eu recours au chômage partiel
ont versé des dividendes en 2020 et 2021
preuve de leur bonne santé financière et
l'évasion fiscale n'est jamais bien loin
100% des multinationales du cac 40 ont
touché des aides exceptionnelles y
compris celles qui ont versé de généreux
dividendes en 2020 par ailleurs
l'évasion fiscale pratique courante chez
les multinationales est toujours
largement impunie lvmh possèderait ainsi
305 filiales dans les paradis fiscaux et
même si les entreprises du cac 40 sont
en parfaite santé elles ont annoncé sans
2500 suppressions d'emplois dans le
monde depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire dont près de la moitié en
france à titre d'exemple leur fortune
est telle que les bénéfices engrangés
entre mars et décembre 2020 par les 10
hommes les plus riches du monde
suffiraient à financer est la
vaccination de l'ensemble de la
population mondiale et pour en parler
nous sommes avec henri sterdyniak
membres des économistes atterrés
henri sterdyniak bonsoir merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
ce soir sur rtl france alors on viens de
l'entendre les riches sont devenus
encore plus riche et ce malgré la crise
sanitaire et économique alors comment
est-ce qu'on peut le comprendre
il faut savoir que les taux d'intérêt
sont extrêmement faibles ils sont nuls
parfois même négatif est temps que la
valeur des entreprises est extrêmement
élevé et donc on se retrouve avec des
entreprises et la bourse française le
cac40 qui a augmenté de 25% par rapport
à sa valeur de 2019 qui a augmenté de
50% en or au creux de 2020 est donc
naturellement les propriétaires de ces
entreprises en bénéficient même vivement
et donc jean leur fortune si on peut
dire qui a augmenté de 25% par rapport à
ce qu'elle était en fin 2019 alors ces
entreprises du cac 40 elles ont aussi
bénéficié des aides de l'état en france
pendant la pandémie c'était absolument
nécessaire est ce que ces entreprises
risquaient finalement elle aussi couler
sans ces aides
et sur les entreprises ne risque pas de
couler le gouvernement a fait un choix
on peut plus ou moins disputer le choix
de quoi qu'il en coûte donc il a ouvert
le chômage temporaire à toutes les
entreprises même les entreprises qui
auraient pu
supporter le conserver leurs salariés
durant cette période mais le
gouvernement pour voulu courir de
risques donc le chômage temporaire a été
ouvert à toutes les entreprises et
grosso modo c'est pareil pour toutes les
mesures que ce soit le 10 milliards de
baisses du dax à la production la baisse
de l'impôt sur les sociétés qui part de
34 8 3 à 25 % pour les aux entreprises
tout ça est donné sans le moindre
contrôle sans condition en matière
mannequin emploi sans condition en
matière de
lutte pour le changement
climatique et il ya eu quelques
conditions qui ont été donnés en 2019 en
2020 ou pas augmenter les dividendes
augmenter les salaires des cadres
dirigeants dans ce cas mais les
entreprises du coût sera pas en 2021 et
donc que les dirigeants vont avoir en
2021 les revenus très importante que ils
ont pas touché en 2011 a donc tout va
bien pour eux et en même temps tout va
bien pour eux mais il ya plus de 60000
postes dont près de la moitié en france
qui ont été supprimés là encore comment
est-ce qu'on peut le comprendre
disons qu'ils vont bien parce que parce
que justement ils ont supprimé des
postes le but de ces entreprises de 4 42
entreprises multinationales c'est avant
tout de maximiser le profit des
actionnaires et donc maximiser les
profits des actionnaires ça veut dire
obligatoirement essayer de licenciés en
france et pourra les produire moins cher
dans les pays à bas salaires c'est la
logique même du capitalisme
financier mondialisé
qui qui qui qui joue à plein dans cette
danse est à présent lire
les dirigeants des grandes entreprises
ne sont pas des philanthropes ainsi
peuvent effectivement faire des
économies au profit des actionnaires il
fonds est par ailleurs pour donner un
signal fort aux actionnaires et
augmentent les dividendes les dividendes
maintenant sont supérieurs aux filles
d'évidentes de 2021 sont très supérieurs
aux profitent de 2004 pour bien montrer
vos aux actionnaires qui en fait tout va
bien pour eux et donc c'est la logique
même du quai du
capitalisme il faut
présenter une
une façade la plus attrayante possible
pour les actionnaires et par ailleurs
nous demande massivement les dirigeants
des entreprises pour remercier les
dirigeants des entreprises de leur bonne
gestion ce qui là aussi est un message
pour les actionnaires alors on se
souvient pourtant pendant cette pandémie
certains se sont pris à imaginer un
capitalisme raisonnable plus vertueux on
parlait de ce fameux monde d'après son
vous concernant l'économie quel monde
d'après se dessine finalement rien ne
change
eh bien nous sommes devant une
contradiction importante que notre
société devra résoudre soient
effectivement on s le capitalisme
fonctionne est tel qu'il est avec des
entreprises qui veulent maximiser leurs
profits ce qui suppose maximiser le
chiffre d'affaires ce qui suppose
développer
des besoins toujours grandissants
grandissant chez les consommateurs soit
on prend au sérieux les contraintes
écologiques dit que les entreprises
maintenant elles doivent être gérés en
fonction d'eux des nécessités de 7 3 200
transition écologique et sociale et à ce
moment là ça veut dire eux ont une
planification écologique dans lequel
elle dit aux entreprises
notre grande préoccupation aujourd'hui
ça doit être de réduire l'empreinte
écologique de vos activités de
satisfaire les besoins d'aidé des
consommateurs mais en réduisant les les
comptes rappeler les dégâts écologiques
et en évitant en évitant de créer des
besoins inutiles chez les consommateurs
à sa demande que effectivement à sa
demande un changement de gouvernance des
entreprises avec un poids beaucoup plus
important des salariés un poids beaucoup
plus important des collectivités la 4ème
fois beaucoup plus importants des
usagers façon générale était
et est
le fait qu' il faut se les entreprises
doivent s'inscrire dans la planification
écologique à certaines entreprises qui
sont peu utile il faut leur dire
clairement ben désolé il faut réduire
notre activité par contre on a besoin
de souffler de développer d'autres
activités la rénovation des logements
donc changer nos manches merci beaucoup
henri sterdyniak d'avoir accepté notre
invitation sur arte france je le
rappelle vous êtes membre des
économistes atterrés
il ya un an jour pour jour la russie
annonce l enregistrement de scouts nigré
le tout premier vaccin au monde contre
le colis de 19 1 malgré une efficacité
démontrée dans une multitude de pays le
sérum russe peine encore à convaincre
l'union européenne de l'homologuer les
détails avec antoine gayraud
le 11 août 2020 alors que l'humanité se
débattait en pleine pandémie la russie a
pris tout le monde de court en avançant
l'homologation du premier vaccin contre
le coc vie 19 6 omnium the biggest gijon
ce matin pour la première fois au monde
à vaccins contre le nouveau coronavirus
a été enregistré à
9 tonnes
je sais qu'il est assez efficace qu'il
donne une immunité durable je le répète
il a passé tous les tests nécessaires
accusé d'avoir été lancé dans la
précipitation et avec un manque de
transparence le vaccin ce boutique v est
accueillie avec scepticisme à l'étranger
nos homologues étrangers qui semble-t-il
ressentent une certaine rivalité et
voient les avantages du vaccin russe
temps d'exprimer des opinions qui selon
nous sont complètement infondées
jusqu'à la publication d'un article de
la prestigieuse revue médicale
britannique de 27 qui estime que le
candidat vaccin déclencher une réponse
immunitaire et n'entraîne pas d'effets
indésirables graves la même revue qui a
annoncé un peu plus tard une efficacité
de 91,6 % contre les formes
symptomatiques ducobu 19 de quoi faire
changer d'opinion bon nombre de
personnes en effet beaucoup de pays
commencent alors à s'intéresser de près
aux vaccins russe qui au passage est
meilleur marché et plus faciles à
conserver que ses concurrents la russie
en parlait de la vaccination de sa
propre population commence à exporter
des doses de spoutnik à travers le monde
argentine algérie mexique sont parmi les
premiers acquéreurs un an après son
lancement le vaccin est autorisé dans 69
pays représentant une population totale
de 3 7 milliards de personnes des
accords de coopération permettent en
outre sa fabrication dans 14 pays
d'autant que le vaccin se montre tout
aussi efficace également contre les
variants ducobu 19 responsables de
nouvelles flambées épidémiques
ces derniers mois
[Musique]
comme le montre l'expérience de la mise
en circulation pour la population le
vaccin est complètement sûr et hautement
efficaces il est efficace non seulement
face aux variants contre lesquels il a
été créé mais aussi contre les nombreux
variant qui sont apparus au cours de ces
derniers temps et qui nous attaquent
constamment j'espère que le vaccin sera
tout aussi efficace à l'avenir et qu'il
protégera bien notre population ainsi
que les populations des pays qui ont
décidé d'utiliser ce médicament
mais voilà russie oblige le sujet de la
vaccination est rapidement devenue
politique insiste poutine v doit être
validé par l' agence européenne des
médicaments afin de se voir ouvrir le
marché européen début mars le dossier
déposé mais depuis toujours pas nouvelle
et du côté du gouvernement français on
est particulièrement réticent face au
vaccin russe à la manière dont ces jets
récit plus un moyen de propagande et de
diplomatie agressive qu'un moyen de
solidarité et dead sanitaires il y à
certains pays comme l'espagne qui
étaient tentés ou qu'ils ont fait à un
moment la reconnaissance de certains
vaccins comme le russe ou le chinois
nous ont dit aux partenaires européens
on leur a dit encore ces derniers jours
attention et non pour ses vaccins
certains dirigeants au sein de l'union
européenne se montre on ne peut plus
pessimistes et il va jean rouch football
on constate que scout nick n'a pas
encore été approuvé par le m&a et ne le
sera peut être jamais
pourtant à l'intérieur même de l'europe
d'autres pays ont fait le choix du
vaccin russe c'est le cas de la hongrie
de la slovaquie mais aussi de saint
marin dont la population a
majoritairement été vaccinés avec scout
élevé
selon nos données le vaccin offre une
efficacité élevée elle est proche de 100
% grâce à la vaccination spoutnik vais
tous les habitants de saint marin ont
développé des anticorps
et depuis le 4 août dernier les
certificats de vaccination sportives et
de saint marin sont désormais reconnus
dans l'union européenne peut-être un
premier pas vers sa reconnaissance en
attendant la pandémie est encore loin
d'être terminée et la vaccination est à
ce jour la stratégie la plus efficace
pour la combattre et un an après son
lancement spoutnik vais continuer à
prouver qu'il est une arme de choix dans
cette bataille et c'est la fin de cette
édition merci à vous d'avoir suivi
proche un point sur l'actualité dans une
trentaine de minutes rester avec mon
cher
tout à l'heure
[Musique]
le crime est tellement épouvantable que
je pense qu'une partie de l'église mais
comme une partie de la société ne veut
pas le voir de 1950 à aujourd'hui le
travail de la commission a permis
d'identifier trois mille victimes 1500
agresseurs ces chiffres sont forcément
très en deçà de la réalité puisque